your bio says that your phone online you
say Ellie is the worst one town for any
aspiring yeah yeah that's a big
hyperbolic but living in LA as a
filmmaker in debt like an independent
filmmaker living in LA is is a blessing
and a curse where where I live the town
in which I live there are numerous
television and movie productions being
shot numerous I mean if they're like the
squirrels I mean at least once a month
but more often about twice a month
they're there I just the other day I was
walking literally walking my son on the
side of went there's Forest Whitaker and
French Stewart doing a scene from the TV
show he's on um like Sandra Bullock
they're all you know but see you think
oh yeah that's that's where you want to
be there there right okay going back to
nobody Phil thinking I have no access to
these people okay I'm actually in the
way you know there's cops there to keep
me away okay first and foremost secondly
the problem is in Los Angeles because
the studio's dominate here the
infrastructure the filmmaking
infrastructure is geared toward the
studios and the studio's make
multi-million dollar films which means
very big budgeted type fees and costs
including the rental houses and
including things like permits to fill
this is something most people have never
even heard of in other towns a permit to
film in Los Angeles you need to pay
like 600 bucks or 800 bucks something
like that to just apply for a permit and
then if they grant you a permit they may
tack on like a police officer that needs
to be there whom you need to pay hourly
for now this is nothing for a studio 800
bucks you know that's like the price of
the mms for the actor you know but for
us that's a lot of money so the problem
is the infrastructure is geared towards
the studio system which is big budget
but when you're an indie filmmaker who
wants to just set up a tripod with your
friends on the sidewalk and shoot a film
you can't it's illegal you might get
arrested you know number two business
owners and Los Angeles are sick and
tired of it you know they're they're
savvy to it so they know they can make
about to 3,000 bucks to shoot in their
bar so they're not going to let you go
do it unless again it's a close friend
or family member and this is very
important very important the sexy factor
of filmmaking of the movies doesn't
exist in LA it does a little bit people
are still starstruck but it's not as
prominent sa Middletown you know America
where people are excited about the
notion of a film being made in their
town in their restaurant so they'll they
embrace you so that's why be an LA
native is a blessing a curse for me but
granted on the flip side of course there
are a lot of resources available such as
numerous actors rental houses crew
talented crew feeders there's a lot of
independent theaters in LA but again
funny so Ellie gets a bad rap a lot of
times they say people here are selfish
what I've noticed is that people that
are from here that grew up here are not
actually really nice people it's usually
the transplants kaput we are actually
the ones that I hate this so what did
you take and I'm sure these people don't
do it to be malicious but what is your
take on the mindset of people that come
to LA mm-hmm I think it's there's a lot
of naivety and I wrote a blog post
called Los Angeles won't make your movie
my call them the pilgrims and i believe
it's like the promised land you know a
lot of people again i'm speaking in
generalizations who's there's a lot of
wise mature well-researched people that
come out here but but my experience and
I've been on a lot of low-budget no
budget sets even though the talkative
folks that literally like just got off
the car you know there's this a lot of
naivety and there's this false
assumption that being here will make
your career it's like in the air or in
the water it's kind of like going to
Vegas is going to make you rich it
doesn't so I think that's a major
obstacle that people bring with them a
major false assumption that people bring
with them that somehow being here like
people are going to discover that people
are going to want to collaborate with
them they're beautiful they were like
the drama star in their town so being
here like the agents and everyone's
going to do you're like a drop in the
ocean I mean I'm sorry but that's the
truth nobody cares about you nobody
cares about your hopes and dreams nobody
so in many ways you are leaving behind
your greatest asset which is your only
fan base your friends and your family so
I think it'd be
people to stay there do that creative
work do that hard work in your hometown
make that film with your resources do
your best with what you have establishes
yourself and then make it so you must be
in Los Angeles where you have no other
choice you just have to be here
professionally that's my opinion
you